as we say good morning to Hank Aaron all
the Famer and on this day that 46 years
ago he homered off al downing and number
715 how are you Hank I'm fine dan how
are you I'm doing okay I actually went
back and listened to Vin Scully's call
of the home run when's the last time you
sat down and watched that oh my goodness
it's been a while it has been a long
time dan I haven't I haven't watched it
that much what do you remember about
that night like is there something that
never came out or something that just
special for you something before the
game after the game that happened about
that night was my mother she she was she
seems so enthused she was so happy and
and when I hit the home run and got
around the bases to home plate she grabs
me and I had never been there before in
my life like that I did notice that that
she was holding on for dear life to you
she just didn't want to let you go no
she didn't she she was quite happy and I
was and I was thrilled what did you keep
from that night I think I remember that
night I remember most was the fact that
what did you keep your uniform did you
keep the bad did you like what what
memorabilia did you keep from that night
I don't think anything is that good son
oh I don't think I don't think I kept
anything I think I went home dan I think
I went home my wife and I bull and we
prayed and and and I got forgiveness and
thanked him for everything that he had
done for me and and and that's the thing
I remember most did you thank him for
that pitch that al threw to you there
was up in the strike
a lot of people talk about that pitch
but that was you know dot you know he
was quite a picture he went 20 games
before yeah yeah you know he used to be
a Georgian Yankees and he was quite a
picture and I had never had good luck
against him and for some reason it was
the night that come calling and I hit
the home run off of her and you homered
in Cincinnati off Jack Billingham and
then I think did Bowie Kuhn the
Commissioner want you to wait to go to
Atlanta or you wanted to wait to go to
Atlanta to try to set the record there
he made you play that maybe the next day
in Cincinnati does that sound right yes
she wanted me he wanted me to play the
next day yes he wanted me and still
instead of instead of I I opened the
season up I hit the home run and then I
wanted to wait and do the rest of it in
know and in Atlanta here and he said no
he said you buy your record so you
played every other day and said you
should play today
how would your career been if you played
in a bigger market I think it would have
been a lot a lot different but then I
don't know you know I kind of were you a
small market got like you were in
Milwaukee in Atlanta if I swapped you in
Willie Mays or you and Mickey Mantle
would your personality would you've done
okay in New York as opposed to Atlanta
in Milwaukee but I don't know that I
would have I would have been the same
type of ball player that I was
that I was in know walking Milwaukee was
was made for me yeah I loved Milwaukee I
was a country
milwauke with a country fitted and I
just love being in Milwaukee what other
sports did you play growing up I played
I played a little basketball no I'm
sorry I'm sorry not basketball take it
back
looking at basketball I played a little
football play a little football but
other than that then I didn't play any
other sport I played baseball I was a
strictly a baseball player I played
baseball from from eight years old until
I got to be 12 or 13 how could a running
were your running back I can run I
couldn't run pretty well I didn't I
didn't have the the the the the feet
like some of these wide receivers a
running backs head but I could I could I
could I could make I couldn't make hey
you can make do things I could do things
that I wanted to do but I also I think
how much it was the most you weighed 180
maybe was 180 Wow that was it I never
weighed more than 180 I always if like
if I got 185 190 pounds
I was overweight but you had those quick
risks like Mike Schmidt and you were the
two guys I just remember it was a flick
of the wrist because you weren't a big
guy I think your lower body was a little
bigger but how do you explain all of
those home runs with not being a big guy
for some reason I don't know why but I
had very strong hands and I had very
strong wrists and I did everything with
my wrist yeah you did it quite well 46
years ago tonight he hit hold on numbers
7:15 we're talking to Hank Aaron you
know we've talked about this before you
were kind enough to share your feelings
going into this that you got letters
horrible letters people didn't want a
black men breaking Babe Ruth's all-time
home run record and then here you are in
the south you hit the home run and then
you have these two fans who run on the
field
as you're rounding second what were you
thinking yes yes these two kids ran on
the field and actually they meant
nothing they didn't mean to do in a harm
to me they had said before the game
started that if I hit a home run time
presented itself that they were going to
run on field and make themselves
presentable it looked like they were
trying to take off your batting helmet
well you know and one of them can I have
to be a doctor and they allowed to be
pretty good citizen oh man I cried that
night when you Homer I was watching in
Cincinnati and of course I'm a big Red
Machine guy but yeah I had your poster
up on the wall and I I just I still have
that that I think it was McGregor that
had the poster with every one of the
names of the pitchers that you hit home
runs off of leading up to 715 do you
remember that poster yeah yeah you know
I should send it to do you collect
memorabilia at all if I go in now I
don't everything you know everything I
have that everything everything brings
watches anything that I have I've given
it to Cooperstown I give everything I
ever add to Cooperstown I don't know
anything and somebody said well why did
what you do it why said it belongs to
Cooperstown I said I played baseball
before people lots and lots and lots of
people and I
they belong for them to enjoy they want
to go to Cooperstown to look at it
that's what they need to do and I also
thought at the time when bonds broke
your record it was unfair to bring you
into that I always felt bad about that I
I don't know how you felt but it was
like who do you think is the old-time
homerun champ like I I always viewed you
is the old-time homerun champ he had
more home runs
you're the old-time homerun champ that's
the way I always answered it but what
Thanks did you feel uncomfortable when
you were asked about that with bond like
you were brought into it somehow
explained Barry Bonds I felt like you
know they were unfair in saying let me
bring you in like in what do you think
of bonds breaking your record and like
they were bringing you into a
controversy there I just and the only
way that I could get out of it was the
fact that make up statement and get it
out of the way yeah yeah well it's great
to have you I'm doing okay I'm telling
it you know I've been watching you show
you you're doing a magnificent job well
I'm during the commercial break here I'm
gonna go back and if I can get a
cameraman I'm gonna show that poster to
you and and I I mean it I'd love to send
it to you if it but it's you and it's
McGregor sporting goods and it's got all
your your home runs that you hit do you
remember that first one I do what who
did you hit it off of big rashia ok what
did he throw you I love you your
treasure and you know I hope we get many
more anniversaries to talk about this
but thank you again I I know you're
probably being inundated with people
wanting to talk to you on this
anniversary and thank you you always
have a place in my heart thank you very
much Dan and
not to you and may God bless you all
right that's Hank Aaron Braves Hall of
Famer